[Música]
'cuba lleva meses bajo constantes
apagones que dificultan el diario vivir
y generan pérdidas económicas para los
negocios privados la unión eléctrica de
cuba informa regularmente de esos cortes
con anticipación pero admite su falta de
capacidad para satisfacer la demanda
en el día de ayer se afectó el servicio
por déficit de capacidad durante las 24
horas del día la máxima afectación en el
horario pico fue mil 11 megavatios a las
20 40 horas el servicio se mantuvo
afectado durante toda la madrugada de
hoy
la crisis eléctrica es tal que de los 31
días de julio en 29 se registraron
apagones y en lo que va de agosto el
comportamiento es similar según datos
oficiales esas interrupciones han
provocado varias protestas en distintas
localidades según medios independientes
el gobierno de cuba respondió a una
segunda noche de manifestaciones en
nuevitas deteniendo y agrediendo a
manifestantes pacíficos esta represión
no detendrá sus legítimas protestas
contra la represión y los continuos
apagones
el gobierno cubano dice que la crisis
eléctrica se debe a las obsoletas
centrales termoeléctricas y la falta de
fondos para mantenimientos una situación
agravada por las sanciones externas y el
incendio industrial ocurrido en matanzas
a principios de agosto la isla no tiene
dinero para comprar crudo en el exterior
y su principal proveedor venezuela está
suministrando le menos cantidad los
apagones reviven el fantasma de lo
vivido durante el periodo especial de
principios de los años 90 tras el
derrumbe del bloque soviético